Some say Apple just wouldn't be Apple without Steve Jobs.
Today, Apple is going to reinvent the phone.
So, it came as no surprise that Apple shares plunged Monday...
...after the man who built the first Apple computers in his garage in 1976,...
...and later introduced the world to the iPod, the iPhone, and the iPad,...
...suddenly announced his second medical leave in two years.
New York Times Technology writer Nick Bilton says the news caught many by surprise.
I think this news came completely out of nowhere...
...and nobody knows what's going on, or how long he's gonna be gone for.
Known for his secrecy, Jobs is a survivor of pancreatic cancer.
Receiving a liver transplant in 2009...
...after initially claiming his medical problems were the result of a hormone imbalance.
Despite the initial hit on Monday,...
...which saw the company lose as much as 20 billion dollars in market value,...
...analysts say, Apple shares are set to rebound after better than expected earnings.
Apple reported a blockbuster quarter late Tuesday with revenues up 71%.
That means, holiday shoppers snapped up more iPhones and iPads than analysts expected.
But the Wall Street Journal's Kara Swisher...
...questions the company's long-term future without its charismatic founder.
There is no replacement for Steve Jobs.
It's hard to find a successor to someone like him.
Based on the latest earnings,...
...analysts say Apple is on track to sell more than 17 million iPods,...
...15 million iPhones, and more than 6 million iPads in 2011,...
...with or without Steve Jobs.